and this is the wired order complete
interview
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
let's go okay
leaders
[Music]
[Applause]
later but then in the group you know the
youngest is always on top so yeah
oh it's great kids
[Laughter]
[Applause]
if you think about it like age-wise you
are in the middle of it yeah
is very good yeah he's looking guy thank
you always enter okay next one who is
three kids
[Music]
everyone no no I am alive
yes fine you're the one yes I am Visual
and this is just a serious
ly handsome guy handsome guy good
looking guys
the face the face of the group yes let's
say it's all the members yeah okay
who is straight kids
[Music]
yeah I mean age goes um the other way
around in our team the youngest two is
the leader and we have the oldest yeah
yeah our mommy is so old John just
kidding
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes all right moving on what is straight
kids
[Applause]
all right perfect
okay is straight kids fourth gem okay
yeah
it was 2018 so that we are a part of the
fourth generation generation yes yes
next one next one does straight kids
live together
oh we did yeah we used to live eight you
know the eight of us all together but
now we live uh four four seconds
I'd say Lino Selena there was one time
where Lino made um uh lamb ribs
and then all of a sudden we just passed
party you know we just had fun
you know is straight kids popular oh
popcorn
do you guys know straight kids yeah
we're getting there we're getting there
yeah we're getting there we're getting
there those stray kids have Instagram
yes
straight kids
ages
26. and then for me is 23 20 24. oh yeah
that's true that's true champion is 22
to 93. kenjin has turned 22 yes
and sing me and they are still 21. yeah
yeah who is 21. oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
raise your hands
this is
yes
stray kids zodiac signs
and mine I'm a Libra Libra Lena is a
Scorpio Virgo uh
yeah okay we have three Virgos Pisces
one two three
when is stray kids anniversary
25th of March
when is stray kids going on tour right
now
um when is straight kids come back just
scary okay
straight kids albums in order
yeah mixtape I am not I am who yeah I am
you yeah and then Clay won oh yeah yes
Play One play two okay
and then was single top and then go go
life right yeah go live go live you're
right you're right
yeah
it was ordinary
good job
red lights meaningful and then so we try
to put that into the song and just make
everything a little very dark yeah
uh I guess very sexy in a way
okay stray kids Back Door lyrics
a special fan chant where we connect
this stays a little bit more close-up so
that would be stray Keys everywhere all
around the world
[Applause]
foreign
thank you so much for today honestly it
was so fun answering all these questions
and uh right now we are on tour and yes
we'll be seeing you soon thank you
[Music]